Leto Atreides the first who would later
become known as Lake to the just was
born on the planet calidad in the year
100 1 48 G Leto would eventually take
his father's role as Duke of Caledon he
was beloved by his people due to his
fair and compassionate style of ruling
Leto is described in dune as having a
narrow angular face with the
high-bridged nose giving him a hawkish
look his skin was olive his eyes gray
and his hair black before he and his
family migrated to dune Leto had spent
the previous two decades ruling over the
planet Caliban alongside his bene Jesuit
concubine the lady Jessica Leto inspired
loyalty and Trust in those he ruled over
and his fighting forces were among the
best in the Empire Leto was also very
popular within the landsraad
the group which represented all the
noble houses of the Imperium Leto and
Jessica had one son together named Paul
the future Duke of the great house
Jessica would later give birth to Latos
daughter Aliyah Atreides the Dune
encyclopedia and the expanded dune books
have contradicting accounts of Latos
parentage according to the expanded dune
books by Brian Herbert and Kevin J
Anderson Leto was the only child of
Paulus Atreides and Helena Atreides the
dune encyclopedia however names Leto as
the only child of Duke mentor Atreides
and his concubine Becca who died during
Latos birth not much about Latos past is
revealed in the original dune saga but
much of the Dukes youth is described in
the dune encyclopedia and in the
expanded dune books both accounts of
Latos life are different here I will
provide you with both versions according
to the dune encyclopedia in his early
life Leto received combat training on
the planet wall or Tetris at the age of
16 his father Duke mentor the first sit
him to the revolt at masque prime to act
as the designated observe
River for House Atreides this was the
first time his father had granted him
authority and thanks to Latos good
judgment many lives were saved during
the assault on the planet later realized
the false in their strategy in response
he withheld the Atreides contingent
unilaterally many har conan ships were
destroyed Leto siege tactics and
sabotage had worked excellently because
of Latos actions then the Atreides
forces were some of the only survivors
of the event after this point Leto has
won the immediate loyalty of the men of
the trade his forces his great judgment
and leadership had saved them in 101 63
AG Duke mentor was killed in a bull
fight at this point Leto was still in
the midst of his military training led
by through fear how--it Leto had also
been trained as a matador and demanded
the right to avenge his father he proved
his bravery and gained the support of
the people of calidad when he killed the
bull with his father's sword
early in lake tous dukedom he was forced
to deal with the mutiny within his own
forces that occurred on the planet pinko
the troops had taken their own officers
as prisoners rather than reacting with
immediate force Leto carefully
considered the situation and realized
that the grievances of the troops were
justifiable he cemented the loyalty of
his troops by ensuring to them that
their concerns would be dealt with Latos
handling of the mutiny is a great
example of his strength as a leader Leto
continued to succeed in his military
ventures and would eventually make a
name for himself over the next 20 years
in 101 75 AG the lady Jessica was
brought to the Duke to be his concubine
she had been purchased from the Benin
jezzer at school Leto gave Jessica
privileges that would never be given to
other concubines in the Imperium five
months later the lady Jessica was
pregnant with Paul Atreides Leto went
out of his way to provide the best
education and training for his son
eventually shadown the fourth who had
once been a friend to Leto grew jealous
of him and at every turn would attempt
to undermine late to his position within
the landsraad the emperor eventually
realized that Latos extremely loyal
troops were on a path to become superior
to his own forces Leto would be too
powerful and a threat to the throne this
of course led the Emperor to conspiring
with the Baron Harkonnen in dune in the
expanded dune books it is stated that
when Leto was 14 years old he was sent
to the Ixion homeworld for his formal
education there he befriended the sons
of house of earnest who currently rained
on inks over the course of his schooling
Leto endured many hours of intense
mental and physical training during his
time on X Leto came to see the
discontent that the sub boyd's had for
their leaders the sub voids were the
poor class onyx they did not like that
the exceeding government experimented
with technologies that potentially broke
the but Larry in Jihad when the sub
boyd's revolted during the play Lac su
invasion Leto and the vernest sons
barely escaped the planet alive Leto
becomes Dux sometime after this when his
father is killed by a bull during his
time as a Duke Leto had come to be known
as an honest man who spoke his mind he
defended house Vernis in front of the
landsraad and many of its members were
struck by his honesty Leto would face a
harkonnen ambush in which they used a no
ship to destroy a vessel they made it
appear as though the Dukes vessel had
done the deed before he would return to
Caledon Leto had traveled to the planet
Chi tain to face the trial Axew who
accused him in front of the entire
empire the soon-to-be Emperor Shaddam
Kirino the fourth vouched for Leto
signing that his reputation was
impeccable he encouraged the rest of the
lands Raph to confirm Latos innocence
behind the scenes the Benny Jesuit
sisterhood had manipulated Shaddam into
leaving House Atreides intact after
returning to Caledon Leto would
eventually fall in love with Jessica a
Benny Jesuit she was given the title
lady after entering the ax tree
household in the original noon novels
Duke Leto moves his entire household
including Jessica and Paul to the planet
Arrakis to take up the fiefdom of the
planet in 10 191 AG it is on Iraq as
that the Duke would meet his end at the
hand of the Baron Harkonnen who had been
working along with Shaddam the forth to
destroy Leto Latos last thoughts are the
flesh the day shapes and the day the
flesh shapes Leto the first was noble
and capable but ultimately a doomed man
the matically his death in noon is
necessary for the sleeper to awaken
Latos death provides Paul with a
motivation to bring down the her Conan's
and avenge House Atreides
[Music]